hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and if you've
read my book the big picture you know
that one of the things I'm extremely
interested in is the project of
reconciling what's called the manifest
image of the world with the scientific
image of the world these are terms that
go back to the philosopher Wilfrid
Sellars I learned them from Daniel
Dennett but it's pretty obvious what's
going on you have a manifest image of
the world which is the world we see and
talk about in our everyday lives a world
of people and tables and chairs but also
a world of purposes and meanings and
other terms that we use to describe how
human beings navigate this world around
us and then we have the scientific image
which if you're a biologist is a story
of organisms and cells and if you're
physicist it's a story of wave functions
and particles and things like that these
ways of talking about the world speak
very different vocabularies how do we
match them up with each other some of
this project is just a matter of doing
science but there's also deep
philosophical issues that need to be
resolved so today I'm happy to welcome
Alex Rosenberg from Duke University a
leading philosopher who's also very
interested in this project of
reconciling the manifests and scientific
images and alex has highlighted a
specific example of this problem that
most of us never even think about how we
talk about history by telling stories
about it when we try to illuminate the
events of history we often tell stories
about what the individual people there
were thinking right what their beliefs
were what their intentions were what
their goals were and how that explains
purportedly why they acted in certain
ways and Alex goes through examples from
Talleyrand
to Henry Kissinger he has a book that
this came out called how history gets
things wrong where he argues that all of
these stories that we tell about history
are essentially useless they're
fundamentally mistaken from the start
because they rely on a certain
conception of a theory of mind how we
conceptualize what's going on in the
minds of other human beings ascribing
beliefs and intentions to these other
people
only the idea goes that we could figure
out what Hitler was really thinking what
he wanted to achieve then we would
understand why he invaded Russia and
Alex has a couple of arguments against
this sort of so obvious that we don't
even think about it kind of view first
that it's been an empirical failure you
know he gives examples where you can say
well I'm sure this person was thinking
that and therefore the next time this is
going to happen a failure to learn from
history by miss conceptualizing how we
should think about history in the first
place and secondly maybe more
importantly he argues that it's
inconsistent with what neuroscience
tells us about the brain you know we
look at neurons the neurons of which our
brains are composed and we don't find
direct analogs of beliefs and intentions
that doesn't seem to be how brains work
according to the most modern
neuroscience so this is an interesting
provocative claim I'm not sure that I'm
fully on board with it in fact I tend
not to be on board with it but this is I
am open-minded about I don't claim to be
an expert so I learned a lot from this
conversation and I certainly agree to
this issue is front and center for
natural ists
trying to understand human beings right
if you don't believe there's an
immaterial soul or an unembodied mind
that tells us our bodies how to behave
how do we conceptualize ideas like
beliefs and intentions if the world is
you know brains are just electrochemical
signals between neurons and we're all
just particles obeying laws of physics
right with no mind pushing anything
around heavy stuff but that's why we're
here on the mindscape podcast so let's
go
[Music]
Alex Rosenberg welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi Sean you gotta get off the
phone I'm expecting a call from Terry
Gross oh that's good you you're
obviously a Big Cheese now with all of
these books you've been writing it's
actually that would be great I would be
very tickled to hear that but it
actually brings up exactly the issue
that I thought I would start I would
start with something a little bit from
left field we'll get into history and
stories and things like that but you
know I started this podcast I've done a
bunch of interviews and when I started
clearly one of my favorite areas to
include in the podcast would be
philosophy it's when my own favorite
areas and yet you're the first
philosopher I have coaxed on to the
podcast and I not for failure to ask
other people I'm wondering is there some
reluctance among professional
philosophers to get out there and chat
about their work in the public sphere
and is this an issue or is it just me
well I just read a interview with a very
fine man a physician at MIT Stephen yeah
blow in which he owned up to the feeling
that at least some of what we do in
philosophy sounds so out of touch with
reality from what most people are
interested in and the stage setting
required to make them part of the
conversation is so arduous that they may
be reluctant to do it you know people in
subcultures like to talk to one another
I already noticed it in fact it's been
about four or five days since my new
book has started to hit the media and
there a couple of websites out there so
on has done something and were just on
something and there's the Twitter feed
is beginning to activate among
historians who are really offended and
in high dudgeon and talking to one
another
about this and the same cultural
phenomena may occur in all of our
academic areas you know if you write a
wonderful book or Brian Greene writes a
wonderful book expounding physics in a
way that everybody can understand it
produces a lot of envy and jealousy
among the physicists and because it's
difficult to do what you do they don't
want to try and perhaps even want to
avoid it and it's probably the same at
velocity yeah but I think that there is
this special thing in philosophy where
even though you know in physics in some
sense the subject matter is just as
recondite and hard to access as
philosophy you know we also in physics
have this direct tangible experimental
stuff to point to right and whereas in
philosophy it's all sort of recondite
analysis and and ideas that are not
completely intuitive at first glance and
therefore maybe maybe there's a feeling
that there's more of a barrier there to
that kind of communication well I also
think that what you do is so much more
exciting and interesting and significant
what a lot of philosophy consists in
then I think that we're more
self-conscious about going public than
other disciplines especially some of
what philosophers do not everything
moral philosophy political philosophy
these are things where people also
listen to what philosophers say more
than I do
metaphysics maybe not so much yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna be a little personal
campaign to get more metaphysics into
the public sphere even even if I'm sad
that they call themselves meta
physicians rather than meta physicists I
can't do anything about that
speaking of healing I want to get mostly
want to concentrate on the ideas in your
most recent book which is about history
and how it fools us
have we fool ourselves by telling
stories but I got to know you through
the previous book through one of your
many previous books the atheist guide to
reality and I think that it talking
about that and the ideas in that book
will help set the stage a little bit so
tell us about the atheist guide what
your goal was there and you know
personally I think that it was not the
right title for the book I mean it's not
really that much about atheism it
presumes atheism and then it goes on
from there well that's right and of
course the book is about a doctrine that
I call scientism and I rarely glory in
the term usually used as a disparaging
term of abuse of the way queer used to
be um another label for the view that I
defend in that book is disenchanted
naturalism that is taking empirical
science seriously as our best guide to
reality and concluding that it jars so
badly with what Daniel Dennett called
I'm following Wilfrid Sellars the
manifest image of the picture of reality
the common sense gives us jars so badly
with that picture of common sense that
we have to get rid of the common
sensical picture of the world so I wrote
that book and at the time was up almost
ten years ago now the New Atheists were
riding high Dawkins and Christopher
Hitchens and Sam Harris and Dan Dennett
that my agent and my editor both
insisted that I had to put the word
atheism in the title even though the
title that I wanted to use was reality
the rough guide and they told me I
couldn't even use the rough guide
because that was trademarked by the
people who do the travel books um yeah
so I thought I believe I succumbed it to
their suggestions and of course in one
respect they were right it made for very
healthy sales in the first several years
and it didn't get the word scientism out
as a term either of abuse or of or a
badge of pride for the doctrine I want
to defend and that was the claim that
most of the great persistent questions
of philosophy especially the ones that
keep non philosophers up at night but
those questions could all be addressed
could all be answered by the sources of
natural science and biological science
and psychological science and that most
of the answers were disallowing just
well in the sense that things like
consciousness freewill morality you're
going to say that our everyday folk
understanding of these issues has been
dramatically undermined by progress in
Natural Science correct and that's your
view called scientism yes science
lucemon generally as viewed as as the
exaggerated respect for the findings of
science and the claims that only science
the mistaken claim that only science can
tell us about the nature of reality and
I accept that definition provided you
remove the words exaggerated and
mistaken right so you're a happy
scientist and I'm not scientists
scientists what it what would be the
noun form of all the substantive turns
out to be scientistic we scientist 6
because of course we're not scientists
right that's the wrong substitute for
the adjective scientistic so you use it
without a now okay so the scientistic
swerd so for example it's just pick ones
to sort of take these ideas and make
them clear in the listeners minds
let's pick consciousness for example we
could do freewill just as well but I
like consciousness it's a little bit a
little bit more substantive discussion
we have about consciousness so do you
think that consciousness exists sure
well people do right they need some
house right about the only person who is
identified and disparaged as denying its
existence is Dennett his famous and
wonderful book consciousness
often described by its opponents as
consciousness denied but nobody can deny
the subjective qualitative aspect of
experience of which we have some kind of
introspective access and where the
denial start is in how much of it we
should take seriously what we can be
confident its function is and whether
it's a basis for any kind of privileged
knowledge of the nature of reality even
about the reality of our own minds okay
I mean this is good so I think that that
even I think that everyone knows
everyone who is slightly informed about
it knows that even Dennett does not deny
the existence of consciousness in fact I
can tell you a story when I wrote my
book the big picture I included that
joke in there that people made fun of
Dennett's book consciousness explained
by calling it you know consciousness
explained away or consciousness denied
and Dan asked me to remove the joke from
from the text he didn't want to repeat
it even though even though I wasn't
agreeing with the joke right he doesn't
he wants it to be very clear that he's
nothing are in the existence of
consciousness he's right to argue for
Sicily against that misrepresentation
and I still think that that book is
probably the best thing written on the
subject I'm inclined to add to it Jesse
Prince's book about consciousness as
attention a wonderful further
contribution but you know but it's very
hard to loosen the grip of our
first-person introspective awareness and
that of course is a large in large
measure what my second book is that's
the book that we want to talk about the
very but so can we say exactly the same
thing you just said about consciousness
about something like free will do who do
you think the Free Will exists I think
that free will does not exist I'm very
there's no such thing the arguments
against it have been with us
Lisa's whole back in the 18th century
and there are plenty of solid
twentieth-century arguments for what's
called hard determinism the claim that
determinism is true or true enough to
deprive us of free will and there's no
way to reconcile determinism with some
kind of watered-down conception of free
will in the way that Hume and so many
others since then I've tried to do have
tried to to do but of course you know
our conscious subjective experience of
free will is what deceives us into being
unable to take that view seriously okay
so but I think good this is where the
what's the phrase that I want to say the
hammer hits the road but that's not
right the rubber hits the road yes
so unlike consciousness I said this is
where Dennett and I I think would come
down on the other side and I think I
think that we're actually in the
majority that's not does mean anything
but don't most working philosophers even
those who are natural ists and hard
determinists come down and still saying
that free will is a useful concept we
should keep around so I agree with you
I am certainly in the minority although
a somewhat increasing my increasing
numbers identify some other philosophers
who agree with me up but of course you
know this is the one area where it seems
writings though profoundly influential
are mistaken and yet they continue to be
endorsed by most people including dead
it however you did a profound service to
those of us who dispute Dennett on this
matter in the wonderful Stockbridge
Massachusetts conference that you
organized and which we can all find
online to this day I hope in which
discussing this matter I finally got
down to admit that the institution of
free will is a concept that is extremely
useful for maintaining social control
in such avenues and areas of everyday
life as are crucial to civilization and
cooperation and our own personal safety
he admitted as much and that to me was a
sufficient concession that he didn't
really hold with the contra causal
freewill which is the only thing that
real free will could consist in well so
this is I do want to talk about this a
little bit more just so that where
everyone is clear on what the options
are so on the one hand yes so this was
the moving naturalism forward workshop
and not only is it still available
online but we finally cleaned it up and
it's available in much more
user-friendly form now that people can
find it if they're interested in and
then did admit that I think that he that
for him personally a big part of
accepting the reality of freewill is
that it makes society more worth living
in right like that is people need to
believe in free will in order to be good
people and things like that and that's
not at all why I believe in free will so
I want to at least lay out the options
here because you don't believe in it and
and it's just it's a particularly big er
issue which is you know we can be
reductionist right we can be let's put
it in exactly free will terms we can be
hard determinists I'm happy to be a hard
determinist there's issues about quantum
mechanics but we can put those aside and
I don't believe in Contra causal
freewill you know I think that that's
perfectly okay to talk about a person as
a collection of particles and atoms
obeying the laws of physics and in that
language of talking about them it would
be silly to talk about freewill there's
no free will there but I also believe
that there are higher level emergent
ways of talking about people we don't
know where all the atoms molecules in a
person are we're not Laplace's Demon we
can't make those hard deterministic
predictions about them and our best our
best vocabulary and theory for talking
about
people is one that treats them as agents
able to make choices and so to me
therefore the idea of whether you want
to call it free will or not the idea
that people make choices and they can be
held responsible for their actions is
not just useful for social control but
it's actually true it's the best way we
have of talking about people well I was
going to interrupt your very eloquent
statement at the point where you first
introduced the word best because I'm
under agree that that free will is part
of a constellation of concepts that we
need and that are best for ensuring the
civilized character of social life but
you went on to use the word best twice
in that eloquently and in particular of
best for telling the truth about the
nature of us as human beings our
situation and the nature of what makes
us tick as they say and before that you
introduced the concepts of you know hard
reduction and emergentism or any rate of
emergent levels of this of the
description of reality and that's I
think where I need to get off the train
well I agree that these concepts are
best for matters and largely normative
and for the preservation of important
social institutions but that doesn't
make them true and if we follow at the
dictates but fall out I think what we
learned from the physics which you have
so Abele expounded for the non physicist
we can't keep free will within that
description of reality right so I think
that I'm very happy to completely ignore
all these issues about normativity and
social control and all that what I mean
by best is really a purely descriptive
judgment of what is best
so my view of free will is that it is
exactly as real as tables and chairs and
baseball and chess it is something that
is not found in the fundamental laws of
physics that if you describe the world
at the most reductionistic level it
wouldn't be there but we have other
levels that we describe it on I mean it
I can say that my chair is made of atoms
but that doesn't mean that the chair
stops existing it's something that
exists at the human level at that at
this level of description that is useful
in the sense that it accurately
describes reality in a world of vastly
incomplete information where we don't
know where all the atoms are I can still
usefully talk about what the chair is
and what the chair does I can still
usefully talk about what a person is and
why they're making choices and this is
what I'm not gonna believe her too much
I just want to say it one last time and
you're gonna disagree right so you use
the word
level of description yeah and I think
that that's I don't know whether
misleading is the right word or
tendentious there's true and there's
false there's not true at a level of
descriptions now you and I both agree I
think and here's the the crutch of the
matter that as I wrote in atheist guide
to reality and I wasn't making an
original claim that the physical facts
fix all the facts right and insofar as
we all agree to that there's got to be
an account of the nature of all the
facts that there are including the
higher-level facts if there are any in
terms of the physical facts and my
belief is that when we know enough about
physics and we've got the computational
power and the cognitive capacities to
see exactly how physics fixes all the
facts it's going to turn out that there
won't be any room in that fact fixing
for the fixing of facts of freewill okay
so just to be perfectly clear you think
that chairs exist you think that
consciousness exists but you don't think
the Free Will exists yes I think that's
a that is a fair gloss on what
I have to say okay and I'm gonna get
back to something that you said way back
in the beginning of philosophers and
their reluctance to to participate in
these kinds of debates I think there's
some powerful or you get Mike for saying
that tables and chairs don't exist
well are you given by a very famous a
very smart American philosopher Peter
van wagon which people have been trying
to refute for 25 years without success
but I don't want to get into that I mean
that's the kind of rare shaped
philosophy of yeah but but I think you
know yes we should not get into it it
maybe I'll have Peter on at some point
or something like that but my point
would be I don't see a principled reason
to accept the existence of chairs but
not the existence of free will like I
could I have more respect for an
attitude that says neither one of them
exists I get that because many tables
are nouns and see their reference okay
and we can stipulate that there are
clear examples of them and what those
examples consistent but if you and I
sought to identify a clear case of free
will right we wouldn't be able to do
that we would identify an action that
somebody undertook and you would say
that actually was an example of acting
freely and I would say it is not and we
would agree on all the facts of the
matter about what happened on that
occasion and yet still disagree about
the three real question got it okay so
we can talk more offline about this but
I think that's actually been very
clarifying and I hope that people get
what the stakes are about this and it's
important because it leads us right into
one of the things you harp on in the
atheist guide which is about Ness
which is something I think that non
philosophers or non philosophy fans
don't even take to be something under
debate right like everyone knows free
will or consciousness are
Hershel topics but aboutness can one
thing be about something else you call
this into question in the atheist guide
that's right and of course nobody
understood it outside of the
philosophical community and within the
philosophical community everybody
thought they understood it perfectly
well and could refute it in the way dr.
Johnson refuted Bishop Berkeley famously
Berkeley said that there there was no
matter there was only ideas and Bishop
and dr. Johnson kicked a stone and said
thus I refute Bishop Berkeley and
everybody understands that that was a
pure misunderstanding of Berkeley that
simply showed dr. Johnson's demons and
that's roughly the attitude I have
towards those who want to refute my
denials about and there I use the word
yep I think of course is the problem um
there is the the obvious fact that when
we make noises as I'm making noises now
the acoustical disturbances that move
through the air and eventually hit
eardrums or get translated into into a
high and low voltage and then eventually
an acoustical disturbances that hit
eardrums um that those have meaning and
their meaning consists in their being
about the world and about truths and
falsities that are made true or false by
the world one of the words that I use
much more lately to describe this is
that our language our words are written
us and our spoken speech represents
right has is directed at the way the
world is arranged and represents as a
picture of his is the very bad word but
representation is most simply
illustrated in picturing about the way
the world is a ray
and in the case of desires and wants
about how we want the world to be
arranged and the question the philosophy
has been addressing within philosophical
circles for a couple of hundred years
now is exactly what this kind of
representation or aboutness or meaning
or content could consistent because we
know that you know marks on a page
acoustical disturbances in the air and
neural circuitry arranged in our brains
they all have meaning they're all about
stuff they all represent the way the
world is or the way the world could be
and the great challenge in the
philosophy of language and Vidkun Stein
of course was one of the earliest to
make apparent this challenge is to
explain what that aboutness content
representation consists in right and
just as I think there's no room for free
will in a purely physical world where
physics fixes all the facts I argue and
I already briefly in the atheist guide
to reality that there's no room for
content in a world in which physics
fixes all the facts and that leads to a
doctrine in philosophy known as
eliminative materialism the doctrine
that I espouse along with a very few
other people which we firmly believe is
the take-home lesson from revolution in
neuroscience over the last 50 years good
so I think that then we're sort of segue
into the history book now but he's still
an atheist guide you talk about this
issue and you bring up the example of a
stop sign right the notion of this red
octagon that is along the side of the
road is supposed to be about the fact
that when you see it you're supposed to
stop in your car and it doesn't show
things stopping it doesn't no naively
represent the idea of stopping at
everyone
knows what to do I was like I guess I
was a little bit unclear in rereading
that chapter and whether or not you
actually were denying that stop signs
are about stopping I mean you say they
are but I think that maybe you were just
sort of speaking in the the indirect
speech of someone
that wonderful phrase of Humes thinking
with the learners and speaking of the
vulgar for almost everything in the
manner in the atheist guide to reality
um there's a take away about about being
allowed to continue to speak with the
vulgar even that we think with the learn
it so free will for example we all
attribute moral responsibility to people
and that seems to presuppose free will
it's impossible for us to stop doing so
even those of us who are heart
determinists we're speaking with the
vulgar but now getting back to stop
signs I use the stop sign as an example
to introduce the more fundamental
problem the stop sign is a red octagon
and everybody knows what it represents
right it represents a sentence variously
expressed in English and any other
public spoken natural language of a one
word sentence it's the imperative
conjugation of to stop then that's a one
word sentence and the sign represents
the action of stopping at that
particular place and time you know
within 10 feet of the red octagon in
just the way that English one word
sentence stop exclamation point has
content and represents and it's very
clear that in ordinary circumstances I'm
speaking with the vulgar that we know
what stop signs mean and we know how
they work and we know what they
represent and now the question that we
want to address it when we're doing
cognitive science when we're doing a
neuroscience when we're trying to figure
out the physical details of how the
brain works is how
there could be states in the brain that
represent that have content that are
about the world in the way that the stop
sign is about the world or in any other
way of example of the stop sign is very
convenient for making it very clear what
would be required by any account of how
our brain states can represent the world
as indeed they must if they are to have
content and meaning and be about the
world right and so but I mean maybe I'm
just being too lacks in my philosophical
discipline here but I would have said
that Vidkun Stein and others have given
us a pretty good account of what that
could mean the the sort of sense in
which stop sign is about stopping is
that when these things that we identify
as cars go down roads and they come to
intersections when these signs are there
they tend to stop and when these signs
are not there they tend to not stop and
that that relationship between the
existence of the sign and the act of
stopping is what we mean when we say
that the stop sign is about stopping but
you you think that account is
insufficient well invocation of the
concept of language game conferred any
illumination on the fundamental question
of the nature of intentional content
that's the sort of technical
philosophical term then you'd be happy
with the answer you just gave but I
never thought that because time told us
anything up that really helped us
understand or explain meaning or about
misrepresentation or intentionality um
he just described the symptomatology
what we need is to understand how the
brain works when it conveys carries
employs deploys meaning aboutness
representation and to wave your hand
about
the way in which the word is used in
everyday life is not gonna help us
understand how it's possible
still less how its actual for the brain
to have states in it like beliefs and
desires that have a representational
content and that problem has been
overwhelmingly serious and not one to
which Wittgenstein or the ordinary
language philosophers have contributed
anything since physicalism about the
mind and the brain became the Orthodox
view in philosophy 50 years ago good so
if we let's assume that we all are among
friends here and we're physicalists
about the mind and the brain so we
believe a queer physicalists about the
universe let's write there's no nothing
else out there the physical facts fix
all the facts we're on the same side
about that is the problem that there is
nothing that aboutness could possibly be
in such a world or is it that there is
something that aboutness could be but
that that something is lacking in the
relationship between stop signs and
people stopping so we could do it two
ways we could talk about the different
proposals that have been made for how a
chunk of matter in our brains or a chunk
of matter at the intersection of two
streets could be about or represent
facts in the world okay um and then we
could show that none of the reasonable
stories about how a chunk of matter in
the world like the octagon the red
octagon at the intersection of two
streets could is about stopping that not
nothing like that could be true about
what goes on in the brain mm-hmm we
could rule out all the reasonable
alternatives that people have so far
offered for how one chunk of matter can
be about another chunk of matter that is
to say how red octagons can be about
stopping at the intersection of streets
in a town
cars doing so or people doing so we're
chunks of matter or you could cut to the
chase and consider the fundamental
profound question of how how it's even
physically possible for one single chunk
of matter in the universe some
configuration of leptons and bosons okay
or to be organized in such a way that it
is just in virtue of its physical
organization about pointing at
representing picturing some of their
chunk of matter some other configuration
of leptons and bosons that ladder is
already impossible but I'm willing to
walk through the various alternative
attempts to show how it is possible and
to try to poke enough holes in them to
make you see that it's just an illusion
well but the latter seems stronger than
I would want toward need right I mean
just in the virtue of its arrangement
etc etc doesn't seem to be necessary
that that I would deny yeah I would I
would agree that that's not there for us
to help ourselves to but this
relationship between the system's right
there's one sort of symbolic system of
signs and what's going on and in
people's intentions and another system
of cars stopping in certain places and
that that for me is more than enough to
count it as aboutness so philosophers
have tried to pursue that program ever
since Dan wrote content and
consciousness in 1969 and the name of
the philosophical program of trying to
show a track and naturalized content
representation aboutness is Helio
semantics Stelio meaning having to do
with purposes and goals and we all
understand that meaning is ultimately to
be cashed in for purpose goal and
or something like that and semantics
obviously well from the attempt to
identify the truth conditions of
sentences whether they're inscribed in
print spoken in speech or somehow
represented in the human brain
so Giglio semantics is the research
program of trying to give a completely
natural biological account of how
content is possible in the brain and in
speech I'm consistent with physicalism
with the doctrine the physical facts fix
all the facts and there have been
sufficiently many in principle knockdown
objections to this program so far as I
can see that it's not going to work and
it's the only game in town if it's not
going to work then either naturalism is
wrong and some kind of spooky dualism is
right or there's ultimately at basement
level no intentionality no content or
meaning or representation it's just a
useful tool like free will right so just
just to put a bow on this and make it
absolutely clear to the listeners what's
going on I would say that you have
recently written a book about how
history gets things wrong you would deny
that you have written a book about that
subject right this is the classic of
course refutation of my I'm not
convinced that there are no desires you
are refuting yourself out of your own
mouth well that's a very you know on the
one hand easy cheap shot on the other
and a serious issue for all of us
eliminative materialists how are we
going to deal with it well probably
there's not enough time in our
conversation to begin to explore the
difficulties and how they might be
circumvented and one of the reasons I
wrote this new book how history gets
things wrong was to try to
compartmentalize at least part of
our our positions so that it could its
its value its payoff its importance for
our understanding of the nature of
reality could be made clear without our
having to address this self or
refutation problem right yeah so I mean
now I'll confess I find the cheap vulgar
self refutation problem up a pretty good
one and I saw that I think that I I
easily get out of it myself by admitting
the truthfulness of higher-level
descriptions in which aboutness and
intentions are all true and real and
they're but ok I get it so I just want
to make people understand we they can
choose for themselves what girdle showed
us that there was a fundamental
incoherence about mathematics about any
axiomatic system strong enough to
contain all the truths of arithmetic I
am not in a position to make the same
kind of claim about our appeals to
intentionality and how they work but I
sort of hope that at some point or other
but we are so limited materialists could
could show that there's an essentially
that there's a fundamental incoherence
here right yeah that would be that would
be wonderful to show I mean I would I
would put what girdle showed in slightly
less grandiose turns I think that he
showed that there are true statements
within formal systems that can't be
proven and it doesn't really bother me
that much the profound fact but I
wouldn't say that the system's
themselves are incoherent they can be
completely consistent but they don't
have purchased on every true statement
ok so in the new book to the extent that
it's about anything it seems as if I'm
not gonna let you get off this hook so
easily so it seems as if you're taking
this philosophical point about aboutness
and intentionality and combining it with
some facts about neuroscience and the
theory of mind to explain to people why
the usual way
we have of doing narrative history of
telling stories about what happened in
history is misleading us is that
basically the idea and good how would
you put it yes I think that is the idea
am I going to say um this that having
given up trying to convince anybody
including my philosophical confreres on
good arguments from philosophy for my
limited to this views I realized that a
much stronger and more convincing case
for many of these conclusions in fact
for as much of them as I need can be
made from neuroscience from the
achievements of Nobel Prize winning
neuroscientists who have enabled us
finally to understand exactly how the
brain lays down information stores it
and deploys it and have shown that the
way it does these three things is
entirely free from and has nothing to do
with the theory of mind that
communicates this basic intentionality
that we've been talking about and
insofar as we use the theory of mind
simply the idea that its beliefs and
desires that work together to deliver
choices and decisions insofar as we use
this theory of mind to construct stories
and narratives both in history and of
course in fiction and other cultural
objects and so far as we use this theory
of mind we're engaged in something that
has a great evolutionary pedigree and
that was a quick and dirty solution to a
problem we faced on the African savannah
a million years ago but which doesn't
constitute knowledge which cannot
actually identify the causal forces that
determine human behavior and therefore
all the history that exploits this
theory to deliver its explanations is
wrong right and so before we get to the
details there because I do when I get to
them I'm gonna give you the opportunity
to dig in a little bit to the
neuroscience side of things
but you do a great job in the book of
providing us with some colorful
real-world examples of how we tell
ourselves stories in narrative history
Talleyrand and kissinger and so forth so
remind us of what the sort of ordinary
folk understanding might be of what we
learn by studying the stories of history
all right so my favorite example is is
in the first two chapters my favorite my
two favorite examples we're actually the
second or third chapter ii chapter i
think is entitled how many times can the
German army play the same trick so I
mean created France four times in
exactly the same place in the space of
75 years now how did it do that well you
know the military historians are paid
big bucks to try to figure out to
explain the past and to explain the past
in ways that will enable us to prepare
for the future and in each of these
cases having very carefully explained
what it is that the Germans wanted and
why it is that they believe that the way
to get it was to to invade France
through the Ardennes a dense forested
area between Belgium and the Swiss
border having explained that four times
nobody on the Allied side French British
or American when it came to the Battle
of the Bulge was in a position to make
use of that those explanations because
they were always wrong um they were
always wrong because they're the
conclusions drawn from them was the
Germans will never do that again
and they did and that should have led at
least to humility if not to the claim
that historical explanation even at its
best has no predictive or very limited
predictive power and then the next
example the one I use in particular to
illustrate how the theory of mind works
is you may have asked yourself as many
World War two history buffs do
why did Hitler do something so stupid as
to an to declare war in the United
States three days after the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor when he didn't
have to and when he knew that by
attacking the United States at Pearl
Harbor the Japanese were guaranteeing
that they that the Americans would focus
on them and not enter the European war
for years if at all and instead by
declaring war on the United States he
forced the United States to enter the
war and to fight them first before they
finished off the Japanese um and that is
a mystery which world war two buffs seek
to answer and the obvious explanation is
in terms of Hitler's mistaken desires
our excuse me Hitler's mistaken beliefs
and his unattainable desires and up the
way which we understand why he did that
is by deploying this theory of mind and
it's a theory which we don't even have
to learn because we it was bred in the
bone or or or absorbed with our mother's
milk which we learned as infants and
that theory which is so invisible
because it's either innate or nearly
innate um that theory is on the one hand
the the device we employ to tell one
another stories both in history and
about our own actions and in fiction and
the source of the failures of history to
provide us with any kind of predictably
useful knowledge that would confirm its
explanations as even in the right
ballpark so when you use the phrase
theory of mind
you're not talking it's not a theory of
mine do you that different people have
different theories you're saying there
is something we call the theory of mind
and it's roughly speaking the idea that
people act because in their minds there
are beliefs and desires and we can try
to figure out we can hard identify what
those beliefs and desires are and it's
that very very basic claim that you want
to call into question when it gets
applied to history in this way I mean
you want to call into question generally
but history provides an excellent
testing ground for why it's not a very
good theory at all right so it used to
be called folk psychology and the
British call it mentalizing and in
evolutionary anthropology and cognitive
social psychology and neurology
especially in the diagnosis and
treatment of autism this constellation
of hypotheses that we all carry around
with us and use to explain our own
behavior and predict the behavior of
others is called the theory of mind and
it's kind of hard to state because it's
a bunch of platitudes and obvious
propositions that everybody already
believes from infancy onward and
therefore it's difficult to sort of
extract and Express but you know
cognitive social psychologists have
drawn their box all RG diagrams of the
way this theory works and used it as
kind of a marching orders of a research
program to develop an account of human
cognition and yeah so good this is a
great place I think to get into the
neuroscience of it all so if I were to
be slightly crude about it what we've
discovered is that if you were to open
up someone's skull and to look into
their brains no where would we see any
beliefs or desires all we would see are
some neurons bouncing electrochemical
signals back and forth and it's a lot
more intricate than that so maybe you
can fill in some of the gaps for us so
you know we think or at least if the
theory of mind is right then we look
into the brain there ought to be some
kind of structure at the earth not
necessarily at the level of a single
neuron or a thousand neurons or a
million neurons after all in a single
foxhole
as the fMRI guys talk about if there are
250,000 neurons and that's you know less
than a millimeter by millimeter by
millimeter when we look into the brain
according to this theory guess what to
be divisions portions some some units
that deliver that consistent that's
observed that operate to store beliefs
store desires and then pair them
together appropriately the right beliefs
and the right desires to drive actions
the choices the decisions which people
make and which we explain to one another
by speculating about by hypothesizing
about what they must have wanted and
what they must have believed that led
them to do that okay and there there's
this implicit on expressed probably
largely unconscious set of hypotheses
that we deploy to make sense of one
another and yeah make that yeah sorry
you make the statement neuron electrical
signals don't differ in content this
seems to be crucial to the argument I
mean what I mean sure yeah in some sense
neurons are just bouncing electrical
signals and the electrical signals are
all created equal it's just the timing
and the number of them etc changes from
situation situation but what do you take
from that fact what do you gather what
is the lesson that you learn from saying
your neural electrical signals are all
the same the theory of mind tells us
that somewhere in the brain at some
level of organization presumably high
above the individual neuron the neurons
are interconnected to one another and
vast assemblages of them are so
organized as to consist in beliefs and
desires and nobody among the
physicalists who actually try to
understand the nature of research in
cognitive science and cognitive
neuroscience none of these people think
that you're going to find content or
badness or representation at the level
of the individual neuron they think it's
going to be found at some higher level
of organization of the brain just as the
software that runs the computer than you
and I computers you and I are using
right now operate at higher levels of
organization than the individual micro
processors and the argument of my
book is that try as hard as you might
you will not find you will find higher
levels of organization but those higher
levels of organization lack the
intentionality the representational
content the aboutness that they have to
have in order for them to actually
implement realize consistent be examples
of these states of belief and states of
desire that of theory of mind tells us
actually cause my behavior so the issue
in the in the research program of of the
science and cognitive neuroscience is to
show how the brain implements the
theories of mine a theory of mind and
the results already achieved in in
neuroscience suggests that that program
will not succeed yeah so the part that
seems pretty clear to me is this idea
that whatever we might have hoped to
find in the mind representing things
outside it's not a very literal
representation I mean you use the
example in the book of grid cells in the
mind of a rat trying to find its way
around its environment are not arranged
in a grid the grid nura the neurons that
encode in some sense to the extent that
that's what's happening where the mouse
is it's not a picture in any direct
sense so right so yeah so what does that
mean it's not used as a picture by the
rent so for the information about the
spatial environment of the rat is
recorded in these grid cells which then
sends signals to another closeby part of
the brain called the place cells and the
discovery these grid cells and place
cells is what got the Nobel Prize for
the measures and for John Okeefe and the
way they work I suggest is a paradigm
for the way in which the brain download
secures receives
information from the environment the way
it records it the way it deploy the way
it then stores it and deploys it and
there's no stage in this process in
which the data the information the
discharge of neurons and assemblages of
neurons no matter how large these
assemblages are constitute symbols
representations pictures which some
other part of the rat or the whole rat
uses in the way that we use the red
octagon stop sign to get us to know that
this is the place where we should put on
the brakes and it turns out that what's
true of the rat that it doesn't use this
information as a symbol that represents
anything about the world that what goes
for the rat also goes for us right I
mean I guess it's not completely like I
get it what you think I get what you're
saying I get the point I mean the
there's not quite a piece by piece way
of representing beliefs and desires in
the what's going on in the brain it's
more holistic it to the extent that it
exists at all and therefore you want to
say it doesn't really exist at all that
those concepts of beliefs and desires
are just not the right way of thinking
about what's in the brain I mean I
personally think and you need to get
into this in detail but going along with
my belief in consciousness and freewill
and things like that I think that there
is a higher level description of what
goes on in the brain that does not map
onto individual neurons which
nevertheless make sense nevertheless has
predictive power and is accurate to some
extent and says well this person has
this belief and that is the reason why
they did this and you just to make it as
explicit as possible you just want to
deny that sentences like that should
basically ever be said probably not
exactly so you used to work holistic and
what I want to say is of course
followers have long advocated and
neuroscientists and cognitive
neuroscientists have long hoped to find
some kind of a holistic level of
description of the brain that will
realize the features that beliefs and
desires have to be for the theory of
mind to be even in the right ballpark
and none of the holistic approaches on
the one hand you have even worked nor
been compatible with physicalism with
our commitment to the claim that the
mind is the brain that its physical
facts about the neurons that fix the
cognitive facts about thought and on the
other hand you're quite right to say
that this theory of mind has been very
handy and very useful to us and it's
probably difficult or impossible to give
up just like free will is difficult
impossible to give up we know from a lot
of really wonderful evolutionary
anthropology and X planet and
experimental game theory and and
cognitive social psychology of infants
and primates we know from all three of
those things that the theory of mind was
an indispensable device that we hit on
early in our evolution when we were
still in the Pleistocene at the bottom
of the food chain on the African savanna
with a device that we hit on a quick and
dirty solution to this huge design
problem of surviving in the face of
those megafauna by ganging up on them by
finding ways to collaborate and to
coordinate our behavior with one another
and that this device the theory of mind
worked super well in those circumstances
and those were circumstances in which we
were dealing with a relatively small
number of other people in our immediate
visual vicinity over a relatively short
period of time that didn't
stretch out longer than an hour or so
and within those three parameters the
theory of mind worked pretty damn well
it got us from the bottom of the food
chain to the top in less than a million
years but the way in which we use it now
for predicting and explaining behavior
of large numbers of people vastly
outside of our immediate environment
over long periods of time into the
future is a disaster
and it explains the poverty and
uselessness for any other purpose except
sheer entertainment of narrative history
and this goes along very well with other
you know psychological neuro scientific
results I'm thinking of you know Daniel
Kahneman and system one and system two
and basically what we evolved you know
back in the Savannah was not a
sophisticated form of rational higher
level cognition so much as a long list
of heuristics that got us through the
day that were way oversimplified but in
those particular circumstances worked
very well and you're making the point
that we're trying to apply them now in
very different circumstances and
probably one could make other points
related to you know climate change or
democratic governance or something like
that where they're also failing I
couldn't myself the idea of thinking
about the theory of - heuristic is an
obvious one and I wish I heard that into
the book although there's there's a bit
about common diversity in and behavioral
economics but of course the theory of
mind was a great heuristic in the
Pleistocene it's not so good anymore
so what we do think about when we bring
it back to history going from the
neuroscience back to these large scale
problems so the Germans kept invading we
kept getting wrong why they did it you
know what they would have done someone
could agree with that conclusion while
suggesting a much less dramatic
explanation for it but just by saying
that you know we've got the explanations
raw
we're telling the wrong stories about
why people did things for different
reasons but you think that the idea of
telling the story of motivations and
beliefs is off on the wrong foot from
the start I mean so how do we compare if
we pretend we're being scientists now
not philosophers you have two hypotheses
here we're telling the wrong stories we
shouldn't be telling stories how do we
figure out what if the day that we
should collect to choose between these
alternatives I think the answer that is
really obvious to any scientist we
started out with this hypothesis with
this research program of indicating the
hypothesis the way in which we attempt
to advanced research program and
vindicate the hypothesis and sharpen it
up and enhance its accuracy and reduce
its degree of approximation is by making
predictions seeing whether they're borne
out and then revising our hypotheses in
the light of the failed predictions so
that they will improve and this is of
course the recipe that has succeeded in
all of natural and all the physical
science all of chemistry important parts
of biology and relatively no part of
psychological science still driven by
the theory of mine and zero in history
we are no better at explaining and
predicting the behavior of other people
than Homer was when he wrote Iliad the
theory that we use is the same one that
Homer used when he had and if that isn't
the description of what in literal a
potage called the degenerating research
program I don't know what is so we
shouldn't even try to figure out what
Hitler was thinking when he invaded
Russia or what what the Japanese
leadership was thinking when they
invaded Pearl Harbor that's the wrong
question to ask we certainly should not
try to figure out exactly what
proposition was before their minds
what would the content of their beliefs
were and there was no fact of the matter
if my theory my claim is right about
what they believed and what they desired
because they
have any beliefs than any desires in
their heads in their brains oh but the
strategic situation in which nations
find themselves those are crucial
matters about which we need to inform
ourselves in order to attain national
aims and goals and many of the great
disasters especially of 20th century
hubris in planning and in strategizing
strategic is that the word that my
second favorite president in the ending
in the 21st century strategy yep who's
that that's indispensable but it
shouldn't go by the theory of mind my
chapter about Henry Kissinger is one in
which I try to show how the disasters of
twentieth century or chemical sudras
foreign policy are in some ways the
result of his employment of the theory
of mind to try to get inside the heads
of matter nichts and cassoulet and
Talleyrand
and Czar Alexander at Vienna in 1815 you
know kind of Kissinger made his career
out of using the theory of mind to
figure out what those guys were thinking
about and then telling Richard Nixon and
other gullible people that it gave him
the recipe for figuring out the right
foreign policy to attain their their
policy objectives well well he did win
the Nobel Peace Prize so in some sense
he must have been correct right response
but you do believe that their history is
worth doing you you are in favor of just
a more sort of you glance at it just
there in what you said but there
definitely I don't want to call them
stories but there are things to be said
about reasons why things happen in
history you would just you think of the
useful reason
why are more structural materialist the
state of the nation rather than the
state of someone's beliefs I would not
use the word cause there are factors and
forces whose physical concrete existence
is undeniable and which result in a vast
and less vast changes in human affairs
over time that's history I think there
are lots of great examples of how to do
history completely free from the theory
of mind and those examples provide us
with real understanding of the past
right so we can learn lessons from
history you're not against that no of
course not that's no more doubt than it
was when Darwin spent five years of
going around the world on the Beagle to
learn lessons from history that he was
able to leverage the theory of natural
selection from and in fact you're not
even against telling stories per se
you've done it yourself I wouldn't I
want to make sure the audience knows
that you have a side hustle as a
successful novelist aha
a side hustle indeed I am not only I'm
not against telling stories I think as I
argue in the new book we can't stop it
telling stories it's bred in the bone
it's it's as good as innate we'll never
be able to stop we love stories it's the
only way the best way we can really
understand things I mean if only I were
like you someone who can really
understand physics without stories
unfortunately like most people I am my
physical insights are overborne by
storytelling and much as I try to
prevent them from doing so so we tell
stories we love stories
we are entertained by stories and I like
entertaining people by stories and non
do I like it well they sell a lot more
than my philosophy and also think that
great works of history have become
classics because of the stories they
tell and because we are so enthralled by
them whether it's Gibbons decline fall
of the Roman Empire or Winston
Churchill's of the world crisis his
history of the First World War which a
friend of his once said Winston has
written his biography cleverly disguised
as it is this is something they said
about him in 1921 long before he won the
Nobel Prize for Literature for having
written the history of the second world
war but you know we can't stop doing
history we can't stop consuming it well
history moves the world the Gulag
Archipelago and mine Kampf
are two examples of stories that have
profound effects on the history of the
world oh the trouble is that they are
mostly these these stories baleful and
nefarious in their impact on humanity
and that's why we need to stop taking
them seriously stories how people enjoy
my stories but don't take them as
knowledge just as in well let me let's
wrap up by I want to give you an
opportunity just be a little bit more
explicit about the novels you've written
I mean it's very very interesting
not only the content of your stories as
it were but the fact that as a
professional philosopher you chose to
write novels after having been on a
little bit of a jeremiad against you
know stories being misleading and I
don't think it's inconsistent it's not a
gotcha I think that you've explained
just now very well that there's
different purposes being served but tell
us about what your novels are about
that's very interesting so I wrote the
ideas guide to reality and there were
two feces in the East guide one that
history answers most of the persistent
questions of philosophy and people
didn't much believe that and
second was that narrative explanations
are worthless and nobody even understood
that let alone believed so I decided I I
have to communicate this I'd be a
different way and the way I was going to
do it was by finding an area so I read
the girl from Cracow cleverly disguised
bit of philosophical argumentation and I
got an agent and my agent got a
publisher and between them they cut
three quarters of the philosophy out of
the novel including most of the
Jeremiah's against narrative and most of
the arguments in favor of pneumatics
although I couldn't use the word meme in
a book set between 1935 and 1947 and
would be anachronistic and to my great
surprise this novel shorn of two-thirds
of its of its Darwinism atheism nihilism
short of two thirds of those features
sold 400,000 copies a KUB objection that
people had was the lesbianism a hundred
or two hundred of the three thousand
four hundred reviews on amazon.com have
complained largely Christians
complaining about the lesbianism and
hoping for moral uplift and they
couldn't find any limits unless
lesbianism yet yeah so so I wrote this
book and it was this phenomenal success
and there are some personal aspects to
the book it's a it's a fictionalized
account of my mother's experiences in
world war two experiences so deeply
disturbing that I had to actually dumb
them down Robert had had to soften them
up and pull them up from her own memoir
which I worked on edited and which was
published about 25 years ago
and then I wrote another novel and this
one had a different kind of agenda there
I was trying to show how the american
right wing and the southern racists used
communism as a stick with which to beat
the civil rights movement all through
the 30s and 40s
50 and I wrote that out in terms of a
story an espionage story set in Oxford
in the 50s and is full of real people
along with my protagonist protagonists
who are of course not real um and since
then I've been writing other novels are
written off a third novel about a young
Scottish parliamentary a Member of
Parliament a 24 year old woman too young
even to vote for herself when she was
actually really real history elected to
the British Parliament in 1929 and now
I'm writing a fourth one but I'm still
doing philosophy yeah at the same time
because the these two genres address
very different audiences and very
different agendas narrative is for
pleasure and if you want knowledge you
have to either do science or help others
understand science and that's what my
non-fiction books including this one how
history gets things wrong is about and I
suspect that I was wise to pick history
as my stalking horse instead of a lot of
other interpretive disciplines that also
employ the theory of mind because
everybody reads history thinks they
acquire knowledge in history and will be
affronted and offended by the claim that
they don't and so will maybe take on
this book and try to review and what do
the what do your philosophical
colleagues think about the fact that you
write novels many of them or at least my
department colleagues are extremely
encouraging some of them reads the
novels in draft and make wonderful
suggestions for improvements of theirs
how can I put it about the one really
wonderful philosopher and writer at the
same time who has encouraged me to do
this as a Rebecca
goldstein short and by and large the
other philosophers I know of they ha
what's the word they pretend to not
notice my indiscretions good good for
them they're very discreet about things
all right one last closing thing I would
love it if you share with audience the
wonderful anecdote about the cover
photograph on the girl from Krakow I
thought you were gonna ask about the
cover photograph on how history gets
things wrong which is by far the best
and most entertaining funniest cover
I've ever seen on an academic book if
you're a stamp collector you'll know
about the inverted Jenny of the postage
stamp in which in the middle a biplane
is printed upside down and which soon
became the most valuable American
posters staff ever made by accident and
similarly the but this new book has
dahveed's famous Napoleon crossing the
scent Bernard pass into Italy upside
down right oh that history long and the
word wrong is printed upside down on the
spine but um that's an obvious and not
inside joke it's like joke for the girls
from Krakow is that ice we started out
with a young woman sitting in a German
second-class railway carriage with the
German with the swastika and Deutsche
spy clearly in the window and the words
are often verboten meaning no smoking on
the window and there she sits in the
carriage smoking a cigarette and it was
a perfect cover for Michael because of
course everybody smokes in a book say in
World War two
and so we the design went through all of
its stages and finally it was sent to
Amazon for the amazon.com page and
immediately
we were informed that though they were
perfectly happy to print a book about
the Holocaust in which millions of
people were killed on her the most
atrocious circumstances possible by
murderous genocide 'el maniacs even
though they were perfectly happy to
publish such a book
it was absolutely verboten to have a
cigarette shown on the cover of any work
that was going to be advertised on their
website there you go welcome for both
this is a real photograph right you
didn't staged it it was historical
photograph yes it came from Getty Images
and if you now go to the website and
look at the cover you'll see there's no
cigarette there because the cigarette
was effaced by Photoshop and she was
given a fur collar and a silly well I'm
very happy with the book I'm not nearly
as happy with the photograph as with the
this is what we authors have to put up
with sometime
that's right exactly all right Alex
Rosenberg thanks so much for being on
the podcast Sean it's a pleasure to be
asked questions by you and I would love
someday to return the favor you're as
good as Terry Gross all right we'll make
sure Terry knows that okay thanks so
much Alex
[Music]
you
[Music]